so a couple weeks ago I made a thank you
Thursday video thanking you guys for
subscribing to my channel for getting
over 25,000 subscribers and I posted a
little challenge I said I'd like to
propose that we do a live hangout free
training for you guys you get me for an
hour to answer any question that you
want and and we'll chat it out for an
hour and I said I'll do it if I get at
least 25 comments on that video since
there was 25,000 subscribers I wanted 25
comments plus we got almost 50 comments
so I guess we got to go do the training
and what I wanted to do was get your
feedback on what's the biggest challenge
that you're facing now in your business
and I'd like to try to help you overcome
that I remember when I had my first
business and was struggling and and you
know I didn't know anybody I had zero
contacts there were no people in my
family who are entrepreneurs everybody
had you know safe jobs and government or
big companies and while they were
supportive of what I was doing my family
didn't really give me any advice on how
to be an entrepreneur and I was a
teenager I had zero connections and I
went to the only place where I thought
they were friends of entrepreneurs which
was my bank
I knew literally zero I knew nobody and
so I went to my banker and I said I'd
like some help with my business
that's how struggle and and and
desperate I was I guess and he asked me
well do you need a loan give me some
capital I said no and I don't need money
I need I need advice and and I don't
know if he felt sorry for me or he just
liked me and my story but he put me on
to somebody who put me on the somebody
who put me on to somebody and that last
person's name was John he became my
first mentor and John really helped save
my business he taught me about selling
and taught me about marketing tell me
what positionning taught me about
strategy and honestly without John I
don't know where I would be now I don't
I would have continued on with my
business or given up and gone back and
got a job and so John had such a major
impact on my life and I want to be that
person for you I want to help you guys
out my little subscribers you guys are
awesome you keep me motivated and happy
and excited and wanted to get up and do
more videos and keep posting away for
you guys and so I wanted to have that
chance to do the one-on-one training
with you and I want a theme around it so
I'm open to any question I'm happy to
talk about whatever you want to talk
about that you might remind people to
help you out with but I wanted to start
with a theme and I would start by
sharing my thoughts on it before diving
in the Q&A and so I want you to help me
pick that theme so leave a comment below
let me know what your biggest burning
question is right now the biggest
challenge you're facing right now and
we'll tabulate the comments the results
make a theme and I will let you know
when we do the live training I mean I'm
really excited to connect with you guys
one-on-one maybe it'll be a series who
knows we'll see anyway leave a comment
below continue to believe thank you so
much and I'll see you soon every week I
share inspiring and motivational stories
that really mean something to me
that I hope you'll check out in my
newsletter below
you